I'm curious about the niche thing that
you personally perceive to be comedy I
call it crossing the desert when you
have a joke and it's very funny but then
you like push it too far this is really
just from like doing a joke too much and
of course as is always the case the
symptoms has one of the best examples of
this in the history of Comedy they set
up the joke with Sideshow Bob walking
into a rake it's good
laughs her hat then he immediately walks
into another
this goes on for a long time and
eventually it loses its luster
you keep waiting for them to cut away
but they just keep going
and at a certain point it just magically
flips back to being the funniest thing
on the face of the planet yet again
Palmer where's the dog God I love to
imagine the writer's room when pitching
this one